hello and welcome to this video playing
chess let's play d4 Queens gambit what
is he going to do classical I don't
really know how to play the Catalan well
so what they all do
the g3 business is not really my field
of expertise
I have always played Queen's Gambit
structure so I mean classical structures
with III Bishop d3 and so on what's
going on here rook you won before
winning a piece that's my typical
simplistic way of trying to win games
yeah if I take I'm going to win a bit of
time that's nice
but it doesn't look very critical
probably rather pinning
it's a slightly awkward opinion on the
Queen nothing that should be decisive
why do you think but it is slightly
awkward okay and he wants to take on f3
and force me to take with the pawn sse
form bishop is under fire but if you
take their three king - Queen takes I'm
attacking the horse so it's not really a
threat
[Music]
at least I can play look the one for the
moment
after something like night bd7 I have to
think about it again
okay I wonder if it was now an option
near probably 95 against that
okay
unless it's a blundered something I'm
quite happy with this this is a quite
decent pawn structure with some active
possibilities yeah I wonder if that is a
good strategy for black because my idea
is simply F for Knight moves c5 and then
90 46 and what exactly is he going to do
about it the answer is probably not much
would seem I could have done just maybe
five
okay I mean it is oh it is fine but the
immediate night booth was maybe stronger
it's got 94 not that this is terrible of
it this is even stronger than 94 a very
simple idea to play b5 is going to be
tough too tough to play against I also
have looked 36 okay probably a six now
and then the question is do I go b5 or
what why is that even remotely a move I
mean might be five with with Campo
this is the end 94 no yeah I can I can
move the Queen still should have
probably probably seen it before
okay yeah the time went down don't hear
really quickly I think that was equal
for a very long time
roughly yeah I don't think I was much
going on okay you can analyze that but I
think fairly normal stuff
I played Bishop g3 now take and I think
from here things go well for black the
engine even gives black a slight
advantage after a 6 mm 6 b5 here maybe
maybe this is a bit easier for black him
that's possible a six now that's it's
okay
yeah a success certainly for for black
was fine for black but he took it and
now played 95 now those so Center points
with E for f4 they start rolling and I
think the way you play it
it was the played exactly into my into
my setup this is excellent now d6 is
such a huge weakness you know pa5 is
better
94 though is is pretty awkward even if
you prevent the immediate disaster if
you look it doesn't threatening here and
after the capture Ike retakes even a
queen takes us even stronger g6 or queen
8 we H 1 is a very attractive looking
off very nice tempo and this and now
you're threatening here and here and
winning a piece and a twin si six cannot
cover that that is a very nice more
queen to h1 very aesthetic they are
covering sorry
going to age one opening up this that
the bishop takes the Queen position
that's nice that's really nice more yeah
in the game I wonder I could play before
now ninety-four of course I can take and
then BC five is fine might be five
hundred before I was probably better
even now this is stronger than ninety
four which is also not bad but you know
I was thinking a six but after T six
you're not going to survive that be five
it should falls apart
yeah in the game I got some additional
damn p90 for a queen d3 is I think
simple and oh yeah yeah black
essentially resigned yeah thanks a lot
for watching